un coup de coeur pour cristiano ronaldo
qui dans une interview à la télévision
britannique ce week-end a fondu en
larmes lorsqu'il a évoqué son père
décédé en 2005 père alcoolique mais qui
n'a pas pu assister à ce succès à ou à
la va vite qu'il a pu y avoir c'était
sera activée ce week-end c'était
vraiment très émotive et que c'était
très toujours pas ce qu'il regrette de
ne pas avoir pu mettre à son père le
succès qu'il a eue cristiano ronaldo qui
est le plus grand footballeur
un des plus simples plus grand
footballeur de tous les deux tout et
enlaidissent même voix la regarde ça ne
sourit elle est donc ce matin sur tout
le cycle rules to say what am inn resort
week-end
enfin moi ici maman et les autres femmes
mademoiselle et de démissionner c'est
super émouvant
voilà c'est vrai que c'était ça ça veut
dire non mais bon parler quoi la grille
du sexe concédé larmes la tête mais ça
devient aussi systématique que le faux
trous de mémoire là pendant les prises
de terre tout le font sourire
maintenant c'est devenu un truc obligé
faut que tout le monde pleure au moins
une fois à la télé en évoquant des trucs
un témoin ça me met mal à l'aise non
mais vous pouvez en lire son père
comprend pas vraiment ce que ça fait il
pleurait il est bas de l'arbre plus pas
moins il faut rien n'est pas en doute
pas du tout l'émotion a l'air sincère
mais je vois pas pourquoi on montre sa
maison au contraire c'est un excellent
teasing pour le documentaire qui va être
diffusé parce que en particulier
cristiano ronaldo tout ça comme
extrêmement cadré contrôle et il n'y a
rien il ya aucun moment de fragilité
aucun moment de faiblesse aucun moment
de vérité ont une passe pour un robot
presque une machine qui est bon juste à
mettre des buts là c'est la première
fois qu'on le cap dans ce qui s'appelle
jamin 4 a dit bouge chez vous en vous
quand vous parlez de votre famille vous
je vous ai vu sur le divan vous avez
évoqué votre grand mère vous avez pleuré
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à parler des
grands parents parce qu'effectivement
ils n'ont pas connu mon succès je
comprends très bien qu'ils soient et
mais franchement ce repas skate 2
d'obscène là dedans at on serait plutôt
aux affaires systématique non mais
honnêtement ce garçon a réussi et c'est
vrai que moi dans ma famille il ya plein
de manque
j'aurais adoré pouvoir dire à mon grand
père à ma grand mère j'avais aussi mais
quand j'ai eu mon bac tout petit même ma
grand mère était morte samassa sebo
j'aurais voulu mais la question est que
je vois j'ai un regret c'est de ne pas
pouvoir dire à mes grands parents ce que
j'avais fait que ça c'est pas
franchement on peut pas tout gérer un
regret oui j'ai pas j'ai plein road est
notamment j'ai effectivement pas pu
expliquer plein de choses à mes grands
parents ça mais ça me plaît c'est que ça
ça veut pas dire bien sûr tout le temps
je pourrai pleurer maintenant en direct
à la tv donc absolument
c'est un des grand grand grand manque
dans ma vie ce sont mes grands parents
bien sûr
évidemment il ya parfois une certaine
pudeur chubu kéké qui honore la personne
qu'on voit qu on dit stop la caméra on
se reprend et aurait normalement dû
obliger d'affiché est ce que vous en
pensez mais les larmes c'est pas honte
c'est une immersion par les larmes
cristiano est malin du mois voilà